[Música]
hoy es el octavo día de protestas en
contra del gobierno del presidente iván
duque quien anunció un diálogo nacional
para tratar de parar la indignación
ciudadana y las masivas manifestaciones
en el país en bogotá cali y medellín
continúan las protestas en la capital
hubo choques frente al congreso según la
defensoría del pueblo hay 24 personas
fallecidas 17 de ellos en el valle del
cauca
el director general de la ub me saludó
la decisión histórica el hecho de que el
gobierno de eeuu apoya la liberación de
patentes de vacunas contra el cob y 19
el gobierno de presidente yo bailé
anunció este miércoles su espaldarazo a
la propuesta que varios países han
presentado en la organización mundial
del comercio para suspender
temporalmente la propiedad intelectual
de las vacunas tenemos reporte desde
washington
el presidente de israel rubén rivlin le
otorgó al centrista a yair lapid
principal rival del primer ministro
benjamin netanyahu la tarea de formar
gobierno después de que fracasaron los
intentos de formar una coalición por
parte del premier netanyahu alertó de la
formación de un peligroso gobierno de
izquierdas de fracasar este nuevo
intento el país podría dirigirse a unas
quintas elecciones en dos años
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 cierra blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos a este informativo en
colombia donde hoy 5 de mayo se cumplen
8 días de protestas en contra del
gobierno del presidente iván duque los
manifestantes cuentan con una larga
lista de demandas luego de que la
violencia empeorará durante la noche en
la capital bogotá donde 25 estaciones
policiales fueron atacadas a una de
ellas se le prendió fuego mientras los
oficiales permanecían dentro las
protestas originalmente fueron
convocadas en oposición en un plan de
reforma fiscal ya retirado sin embargo
las movilizaciones continúan de manera
mayoritariamente pacífica y con los
ciudadanos que exigen retirar un
polémico proyecto de la reforma a la
salud y exigen el fin de la violencia
policial en horas de la tarde se
conocieron denuncias de congresistas que
afirman que manifestantes intentaron
ingresar al congreso de la república y
hubo choques con la policía
las manifestaciones han dejado hasta el
momento al menos 24 víctimas mortales
según la defensoría del pueblo y 31 de
acuerdo con ongs locales
nuestra periodista marina sardinas tuvo
en las calles de la capital de ambos
colombia está viviendo una nueva jornada
de paro nacional que prosigue a las
masivas movilizaciones que se celebraron
y que iniciaron el pasado 28 de abril
en principio en rechazo a la reforma
tributaria el presidente iván duque que
fue retirada por el mandatario
colombiano el pasado domingo sin embargo
como vemos aquí hoy en una de las
principales arterias de la capital
bogotana
bogotá los manifestantes han vuelto a
las calles y es que sus exigencias van
más allá de la reforma tributaria en un
país donde la pandemia que se encuentra
en su tercera ola está afectando
gravemente a sus ciudadanos con el 42
por ciento de los de la población en
situación de pobreza por ello los
manifestantes están hoy aquí en las
calles para exigirle al gobierno mejoras
sociales y también una de las voces que
están resonando es el fin de la
violencia policial y es que en los
últimos días hemos visto fuertes
enfrentamientos entre los manifestantes
y las fuerzas del orden público que
están reprimiendo las manifestaciones en
su mayoría pacíficas de forma violenta
aún a unos hechos que han llevado a la
condena internacional diferentes
organismos internacionales han condenado
esta represión contra las marchas
pacíficas
si bien el gobierno colombiano ha
abierto una mesa de diálogo los
manifestantes y los convocantes del paro
nacional no se sienten representados y
están hoy aquí en las calles para exigir
unas mejoras sociales y un futuro digno
la situación por el momento en las
calles de bogotá vamos ahora a eeuu
donde el presidente yo vaya en anunció
que apoyará la propuesta que varios
países han presentado ante la
organización mundial del comercio para
suspender temporalmente la propiedad
intelectual de las vacunas contra el
kobe 19 lo ms calificó el hecho como una
decisión histórica nuestro corresponsal
en la capital estadounidense cristóbal
vázquez con los detalles
la representante comercial de eeuu que
ayer afirmó que la administración de
beijing cree en la protección de la
propiedad intelectual de las vacunas
pero que con el fin de acabar con la
pandemia eeuu apoya a relajar las
medidas de protección de patentes de
estas vacunas contra el coi 19 esto es
importante porque les permitirá a los
países más afectados por la pandemia
como india producir sus propias vacunas
genéricas y responder rápidamente a los
brotes de contagio y no tener que
esperar meses o años por las vacunas la
propuesta de levantar temporalmente
hasta que acabe la pandemia las
protecciones a la propiedad intelectual
de los insumos para producir las vacunas
ya lo había planteado india y sudáfrica
en octubre del año pasado sin embargo
las empresas farmacéuticas habían
frenado la petición argumentando que
esto tendría graves efectos en la
capacidad de producir las vacunas
rápidamente y acabaría además con muchos
empleos en eeuu la representante
comercial de eeuu entonces catherine key
la próxima semana a suiza ginebra para
reunirse con representantes de otros
países europeos y empezar así el diálogo
para lograr el consenso que es necesario
en la organización mundial del comercio
para que se suspendan las protecciones
de las patentes para las vacunas del
comité y vamos ahora hasta israel donde
el futuro del primer ministro benjamin
netanyahu está otra vez en vilo luego de
que en la medianoche del martes y acabar
el plazo para formar gobierno pasaron
cuatro semanas y ahora su opositor yair
lapid tendrá la oportunidad de sacar al
país del bloqueo político y evitar unas
quintas elecciones en dos años
un nuevo intento de romper con el ciclo
de bloqueo político en israel este
miércoles el presidente del país hizo su
elección y este es el hombre al que se
le encargará la tarea de formar un nuevo
gobierno
y partido de centro de yair lapid quedó
en segundo lugar tras las elecciones de
marzo la cuarta votación en sólo dos
años el ex presentador de televisión
también recibió el respaldo de cuatro
partidos pequeños de todo el espectro
político
antes de la decisión de hoy su principal
oponente era naftalí bennett jefe de la
mina un pequeño partido nacionalista y
religioso
la decisión llega luego del impasse que
volvió a enfrentar benjamin netanyahu y
la imposibilidad de asegurar una
coalición el primer ministro tenía una
ventana de 28 días tras la elección no
concluyente de marzo y esto le dio a sus
oponentes esta oportunidad de
potencialmente sacarlo del poder
luego de más de 12 años consecutivos de
netanyahu como primer ministro luego de
dos años de parálisis parece que quizá
dentro de pocos días y pocas semanas
podríamos tener una coalición funcional
que nos incluya el señor netanyahu esto
será una ruptura en la historia reciente
israelí things change in recent street
el fracaso de netanyahu resalta a largo
plazo la fractura de escena política
israelí y tampoco logra asegurar una
coalición el primer ministro en
funciones seguiría en el poder hasta las
próximas elecciones lo cual le daría una
oportunidad de un mandato más
y este miércoles se cumplen 200 años de
la muerte de napoleón bonaparte una
figura política militar que sigue
dividiendo a la población francesa el
presidente de manuel macrón asistió a
los actos donde aseguró que se trata de
una conmemoración más no de una
celebración veamos el informe de alva
santana
en el bicentenario de la muerte de
napoleón bonaparte el presidente manuel
macro en lo definió como una figura de
contrastes destacándolo como constructor
estratega y legislador pero también
criticando su restauración de la
esclavitud durante un homenaje el
mandatario depositó una corona de flores
en su memoria el primer presidente
francés que lo hace desde georges
pompidou y de la fifa
netview para mí en fin napoleón es el
hombre que dio cuerpo a nuestra
organización política y administrativa
que dio forma a esta soberanía tiendas
que salía de la revolución assets
urgente dato no quiso usted la abolición
la figura del emperador sigue siendo muy
controvertida en francia y muchos
ciudadanos lo critican por su
totalitarismo y excesos en las guerras
que el libro
el final de su vida fue miserable pero
es una de las más grandes figuras
políticas francesas entre todas las
reinas reyes y emperadores y en lo cual
yo
otros lo recuerdan por su aporte
histórico al país como la introducción
del código civil mismo que está entre
una gran figura política francesa y
entre un dictador porque aportó muchos
grandes logros como el código civil y
otras cosas
napoleón tomó el poder con un golpe de
estado en 1799 y extendió su dominio por
toda europa revocó la abolición de la
esclavitud en las colonias francesas y
retrocedió en los derechos de las
mujeres en 1821 murió en el exilio de la
isla de santa elena desterrado por los
británicos tras su derrota en waterloo
y de esta manera llegamos al final del
informativo de france 24 os espero a las
19 horas a bogotá quito lima donde vamos
a analizar el panorama político y social
colombiano hasta pronto
[Música]
siga todas las noticias